be a director pick up a camera shoot
something no matter how small no matter
how cheesy put your name on it as
director
now you're a director make a movie every
week and work with actors work with a
little 1000 watt lighting kit shoot a
little scene cut those scenes together
then go out and make another picture the
next weekend make films no matter what
anybody says and you'll be a filmmaker
start making movies is my advice to
anybody you want to be a director direct
make a film show it to somebody there's
no other way to do it young person wants
to express themselves and take a video
camera and go up they're going to find
that they have to frame the image and
then framing the image they're going to
find that they have to interpret what
they want to say you need to know how
ideas and emotions are expressed through
a visual form there's no other art form
that has this kind of situation you can
think all you want and you can dream up
great shots in your head that no one
else has ever come up with or you can do
anything like that but until you've
actually done it you don't know if
you've got what it takes to do the job